[Music]
we cannot as a country absorb 10 million
people and still provide high quality
housing to the rest of our citizens it
just doesn't the math doesn't work the
numbers don't make sense the increase in
housing prices and rents is clear for
all to see
[Music]
flow of illegal immigrants breaching
America's border borders America's Home
Ownership becoming more expensive with
the influx of millions Crossing
illegally right now on Friday President
Biden officially lifted title 42. the
successful Trump era border policy which
allowed rapid expulsion of migrants
illegal migrants the border patrol Union
calling the massive surge that ensued
the worst sustained disaster they've
ever seen adding that President Biden is
solely responsible for this humanitarian
crisis border agents have been
apprehending more than ten thousand
illegals every day since title 42 was
lifted and housing them is at over
capacity so the administration directed
border agents to just release the
migrants into the population until a
federal judge on Thursday evening
blocked the administration from
implementing that policy which would
have allowed for the release of migrants
without court dates sparking outcry from
several States joining me right now two
of the Premier law enforcement officials
in the Country Florida attorney general
Ashley Moody and Texas Attorney General
Ken Paxton great to see you both thank
you so much for being here A.G Moody let
me start off with you and A.G Paxton I
want you to jump in as well tell us what
would have happened had you not won that
uh Federal ruling this week
well exactly what they planned all along
Maria and you covered in your last
segment and kudos to you for pointing it
out the media has dropped the ball on so
many critical issues to the security of
this nation including those pouring into
our country so the State of Florida Saw
in month one of the Biden Administration
that they started mass releasing people
into the interior no other Democratic or
Republican president had done anything
like that in their Administration
although they will tell you differently
and the media will report report that
and and copy that that they have that is
not true so within the first month those
that they were releasing into the
Interior right without without pushing
forward any sort of proceedings went up
571 percent so we saw this happening
over the course of two years of the
Biden Administration they cut detention
capacity at the same time they went to
Congress and said don't give us money
don't give us more detention we don't
need it my orcas went out there and said
we can control the Border we are
securing the border so while that last
administrative title 42 protection was
in place behind the scenes they were
breaking down systematically our
immigration security structures and so
when Florida bought suit we said look
there are mass releasing people into the
U.S illegally a judge agreed with us we
took them to trial he said yep can't
Mass released people into the U.S that's
against the law Biden yeah my orcas and
they did it anyway we uncovered secret
memos showing their plan was to step
back and let everybody flood in wow and
who reported that you were on top of
that Maria but you could I can tell you
the the mainstream media as we were
recovering secret memos as we were
laying out their plan no one covered it
yeah but now as they're watching our
country be invaded hopefully somebody
will pay attention wow
well let me say first of all I want to
say thank you to Ashley Moody for
following that original lawsuit and
finding that secret memo and then also
filing for an injunction to stop what's
going on now Texas is doing something
very similar as mallorcus is out saying
that the borders under control which we
all know is an absolute lie but we had a
case that's except for trial in the
middle of June that was trying to stop
them from flying in 30 000 illegal
immigrants from places like Nicaragua
and Venezuela and Haiti and Cuba and
we've added this portion which is now
with this memo they put on May 10th
literally a day before this this title
42 policy was going away where they said
they were just going to release people
into the public and they were supposed
to provide their addresses and the
report back in 60 days totally ludicrous
we have no way to track these people
they're going to be released into the
country and it's completely illegal
that's
unbelievable and you know it's
it's awning to look at the doj and the
FBI completely blowing off the laws of
this country I know that you both were
watching and listening to the last
segment that I had with Congressman
James Comer and you know a stunning
admission from Comer that these
whistleblowers are at least one
informant is now missing what can be
done here in terms of the doj and the
FBI is are they corrupt as well
they have a job here they're supposed to
enforce the law and we know that there's
all this information about the Biden
Administration and about his family and
you've got James Comer with evidence and
yet the FBI isn't even cooperating with
with this oversight committee so you
know they're not doing their job so I
mean somewhere along the way a president
is going to have to reform what's going
on in the Department of Justice and the
and the Federal Bureau of Investigation
which have become political and they
target Republicans and they let
Democrats walk Ashley
well think about the duplicity and
what's taking place in the immigration
matter they waited until title 42
expired to ask a federal judge to stay
the ruling that it was illegal to mass
release all of these people so you have
a federal judge yesterday that said it
seems like majorcus may be untruthful
here because they've waited so long to
ask for a stay meaning they wanted to
wait to the last minute so is this
emergency that they created so they'd
have to let everyone in
it's almost like
majorcus is Kaiser sose right like he
has this plan the whole time he asks for
Less detention capacity he asked for
less money his plan is unfolding and all
along the way he's like it's I we're
managing it it's tough but we're
managing it don't worry don't give us
more resources we got it then the plan
unfolds the plan is unfolding right now
and the way we hold these Federal
officials is in check is Ken Paxton
myself the other AGS around the country
that are digging in holding their feet
to the fire pushing back and revealing
their secret plans we would never know
about this if we weren't in litigation
right now are the doj and the FBI
corrupt
I believe that there are steps that
these administrative agencies are taking
with the with the authorization and
oversight of this White House the
handlers of Biden that are agenda driven
and untruthful and they are directly
violating federal law so you tell me
there's an impact here Ken Paxton in
terms of the cost what is the cost to
Texas what is the impact on Texas
look and this is sad to say the bite
Administration knows the cost they they
plan for the cost they're sending these
illegals to Texas and Florida Republican
states because there's an economic cost
we have we have to educate Health Care
law enforcement the list goes on but
there's also a social cost we have more
crime we have more drugs the Biden
Administration knows that Republican
states have been more successful and
economically prosperous than Democratic
states and people are voting with their
feet by coming to our states so the bite
Administration has set this thing up so
that we have problems that we wouldn't
have had but for the bite Administration
pushing these illegal immigrants into
our states all right we will leave it
there a big impact on Florida Texas and
the rest of the country obviously as a
result of this wide open border we'll be
watching your work Florida attorney
general Ashley Moody and Texas Attorney
General Ken Paxton thank you both very
much for being here